mario gonzález y su familia viven al
frente del río paz que divide a
guatemala del salvador la prórroga del
régimen de excepción salvadoreño le ha
dado 30 días más de tranquilidad a este
campesino que teme que los pandilleros
lleguen algún día a su casa
a caer guatemala al otro lado si usted
puede ver ya desde el salvador
el verano centroamericano es la época
propicia para que los mareros crucen
ilegalmente esta frontera porque el río
va a su caudal y permite transitar lo
uno voltea a ver para lado el salvador
es por momentos miraba uno que venían
ahí los mareros y entonces uno siente
temor va de calle canillas de llenaba la
cuestión va la mitad mala llevaba de por
miedo con el ejército guatemalteco de
escolta llenar el bidón con agua ahora
es una tarea tranquila esta protección
comenzó a partir de que el gobierno
salvadoreño declaró la guerra contra las
pandillas por la ola de homicidios que
azotó a el salvador en marzo de este año
que dice que lo está agarrando
que dice que hay varios presos yo
presiento que ya no va a ser igual la
vida
me calenté la torre
mario y maría elena habían desalojado su
casa luego de conocer el reciente
asesinato de un marero en el río solo
volvieron porque el ejército redobló su
presencia para mitigar el cruce ilegal
de mareros
dime
no ha visto ustedes de movimiento de
personas extrañas
parlamento muy el comandante del
ejército de guatemala a cargo de la
seguridad de la frontera con el salvador
da un parte de tranquilidad sin
desestimar que se han logrado varios
arrestos de mareros en las últimas
semanas si de hecho la población en un
momento tuvo temor verdad por la por la
acción de de la república del salvador
en este estado decepción sin embargo la
población ha confiado en las fuerzas de
seguridad en el ejército de guatemala y
está en sus hogares
los habitantes de la frontera en
guatemala se sienten vulnerables por que
presienten que si el ejército abandona
el área cuando termine el estado de
excepción salvadoreño las maras podrían
regresar a expulsarlos de sus viviendas
a reclutar a los menores e intimidarlos
por la fuerza